[Musique]
vous arriviez dans le bureau là-bas làb
la page doit être encore ouverte
merde on vivement qu'il arrivent
qu'on en
[Rires]
parle c'est assez intéressant mais
n'existe pas vraiment de sketch drôle
sur le sujet de la pornographie enfin en
tout cas qui nous ne nous ont fait rire
ou nous on en a fait un il est nul ouais
est pourri c'est vrai il est super nul
on a essayé de le faire disparaître mais
il est quelque part sur Youtube je crois
mais ah ben voilà l'interv commence
réellement ça il vous êtes pas maquillé
non
vite qu'est-ce que je voulais le bureau
de ta femme là ouais au fond
[Musique]
là-bas moi c'est je pense c'était les BD
Manara
j'ai voir traîner ça chez un oncle ou un
truc comme ça é petit et tout et tu
fais qu'est-ce que ouais voilà c'est
exactement ce que j'ai d c'est
exactement ce que j'ai
dit ça mene qu'il parle de ma femme
comme
ça est
[Musique]
G quand elle respire la poitrine gonfle
et comme c'est serré la poitrine tu vois
ces films d'époque là avec ses ces
corsets bien et ça débordait tu disait
un moment donné ça va ça va sortir enfin
c'est c'est c'est encore dans la
frustration quand on se dit ça va
exploser ça n'explosait
[Musique]
jamais et les quatre siz ah les quatre
siz alors oui quat siz not les quatre
siz il y avait quelque chose il y avait
la milf ou celle qui tuit un peu plus
âgée la petite dernière aux cheveux
courts et celle au milieu qui pas mal du
tout
[Musique]
en fait le problème c'est d'avoir dit à
Seb écoute à minuit tu peux y aller tu
fais ce que tu veux qui a dit qui a dit
le mec qui
faut il pourra faire ça tu vois par
exemple